you're just walking down the street and
someone comes up to you and says quick
quick
4792 is this divisible by three this is
an emergency tell me as quickly as
possible and luckily you have a little
tool in your toolkit where you know how
to test for divisibly by three you say
well i could just add up the digits if
the sum of that is a multiple of three
then this whole thing is a multiple of
three so you say four
plus seven plus nine plus two that's 11
plus nine is 20 plus 2 is 22 that's not
divisible by 3 if you were unsure you
could even add the digits of that 2 plus
2 is 4 clearly not divisible by 3 so
this thing right over here is not
not divisible
by three and so luckily that that
emergency was was saved but then you
walk down the street a little bit more
and someone comes with you quick quick
quick
386 thousand eight hundred and two is
that divisible by three well you employ
the same tactics you say well what's
three plus eight plus six
plus eight plus zero plus two three plus
eight is eleven plus six is seventeen
plus eight is twenty-five plus two is
twenty-seven well 27 is divisible by
three and if you're unsure you could add
these digits right over here two plus
seven is equal to nine clearly divisible
by three so this is divisible by three
as well and so now you feel pretty good
you've helped two perfect strangers with
their emergencies you figured out if
these numbers were divisible by three
very very very very quickly but you have
a nagging feeling because you're not
quite sure why that worked you've just
kind of always known it
and so let's think about why it worked
and to think about it i'll just pick a
random number but we could do this
really for any number but i won't go too
proofy on it just so that you can see
it's pretty common sense here and the
number we'll use is 498. i could
literally use any number in this
situation and to think about why this
whole little tool or this little system
works we just have to rewrite 498. we
can rewrite the 4 since it's in the
hundreds place we could write that as 4
times 100
or 4 times 100 that's the same thing as
4 times 1 plus
99. that's all this 4 is it's 400 which
is the same thing as 4 times 100 which
is the same thing as 4 times 1 plus 99.
and the little trick here is that i want
to write instead of writing 100 i want
to write it as a sum of 1 plus something
that is divisible by three and 99 is
divisible by three if i had more digits
here 999
999 they're all divisible by three this
is why you can do the same reasoning for
divisibility by nine because they're all
divisible by 9 as well anyway that's
what that 4 in the hundreds place
represents this 9 in the tens place well
that represents 90 or 9 times 10 or 9
times 1 plus 9.
and then finally this 8 that's in the
ones place that's just 8 times 1 or we
could just write plus 8.
now we can distribute this 4 this is 4
times 1 plus 4 times 99 so it's 4
plus
4 times 99 actually let me write it like
this
i'm going to write well actually let me
write first like 4 plus 4
times
99 do the same thing over here this is
the same thing as plus
let me do that magenta color plus
nine
plus nine times nine
nine times nine and then finally i have
this
eight right over here and i can
rearrange everything
these terms right over here the 4 times
99 and then the 9 times 9 i can write
over here 4 times 99 i'll write it with
slightly different notation plus the 9
times the 9 that's those two terms and
then we have the
plus 4
plus 9
plus 9 plus 8
plus
8.
well do we can we now tell whether this
is divisible by 3
well these terms these first two terms
are definitely divisible by 3. this is
divisible by 3 because 99 is divided by
3 regardless of what we have over here
you don't have to look at this this is
divisible by 3 so if you're multiplying
it's still going to be divisible by 3.
this is divisible by 3. so if you're
multiplying this whole thing is still
going to be divisible by three if you
add two things that are divisible by
three the whole thing is going to be
divisible by three so all of this is
divisible by three and if you had other
digits here you would have done the same
exact thing instead of having one plus
99 you would have one plus 999 one plus
9999 etc etc
so the only thing you have to really
worry about is this part right over here
you have to ask yourself in order for
this whole thing to be divisible by
three this part is well if that part is
then this part in order for the whole
thing has to be divisible by 3 that also
has to
be
divisible
by 3. but what is this right over here
these are just our original digits 498 4
a 9 and 8. we just have to make sure
that when we take the sum it's divisible
by 3.